after weeks of waiting twitchcon finally
happened which as big as names came
together to stream celebrate and meet
their fans but the party wasn't great
for everyone in fact for some it was a
nightmare both physically and
emotionally
so twitchcon if you're not sure what
that is it is a convention for all
things twitch so streamers their fans
their mods everyone comes together and
has one big celebration of the platform
this one was in San Diego with many
creators and fans coming together to
have what twitch themselves described as
an IRL party seems fun enough
conventions happen all the time and this
one should have been fine except that's
not what seemed to happen see news
started to break via tweets that
twitchcon wasn't exactly keeping up with
the standards of safety that we would
expect for a large event one of the most
known parts of the event was this foam
pit which as far as I can tell was put
up by Lenovo and Intel I'm sure a lot of
you have seen this clip
sense of her own great Victory there
we'll make sure she's okay get her out
of the pack if you don't know who that
is that is Adriana chechik who is an
adult performer and twitch streamer with
800 000 followers Adrian revealed that
as a result of that Landing she had
broken her back in two places and would
need surgery listen as someone who has
also broken her back albeit with a
stress fracture and not with an impact
like Adriana's spine injuries can have
lasting impacts there are certain things
that I still cannot do because of my
injury and my injury was not nearly as
serious as Adriana but Adriana
apparently was not the only person to
have sustained an injury from that foam
pit Adriana was retweeting different
accounts of people being injured at this
specific foam pit including lock Van
Ness who said that they were at the
hospital laughliness also posted this
video of them getting the injury it said
that they sustained a dislocated knee
and sprained ankle
oh congratulations Adriana also tweeted
why did at Lenovo Legion say here you
can dive in they opened the pit up a
second day after the first person
injured their foot and ankle bad enough
to leave hashtag twitchcon in a brace
multiple people were injured and they
kept the pit open said jump in booty
first as well as special shout out to
the random off work EMT who got the
workers at the booth to realize how bad
I was injured and to make them keep me
still and calm me down until others got
there you really kept me from crying
badly the foam pit was a club by Lenovo
and Intel participants had to sign
waivers eventually the pit was shut down
Kotaku reported a statement from Lenovo
who said we are aware of the incidents
of twitchcon visitors who sustained
injuries in the Gladiator game soft foam
pit at the Lenovo Booth the area has
since been closed for any further use
while we work with the event organizers
to look into the incidents this foam pit
was not the only safety concern at
twitchcon there were serious allegations
regarding what was happening at
twitchcon and its overall lack of safety
and care for its attendees firstly there
were many tweets alleging that twitchcon
was not meeting accessibility needs of
its attendees as well as those with
accessibility needs being put in
legitimate danger as this following
tweet illustrates the fact that there
were people trying to trample people in
wheelchairs to get into this panel is
disgusting and security was doing
nothing we literally had to yell at
security officials to let people with
wheelchairs through another tweet said
that after someone had a flare but ptos
while waiting in line left to breathe
and when they came back security was
quote nothing but rude and did not let
them back in speaking of security there
is this clip of security saying that
attendees were cussing them out among
other issues that security says they
faced
were so verbally abused us oh what yeah
to be clear I'm not excusing anyone's
Behavior this is just what was said
Steve Saylor a twitch Ambassador wrote
being a twitchcon using the
accessibility Services I saw some faults
most of them had to do with the
convention center staff security and not
the twitch staff I also did hear it
being suggested to get an accessibility
sticker to skip lines even if not
disabled that's true there was an entire
thread dedicated to the apparent
numerous issues at twitchcon where a lot
of these tweets come from detailing
pretty harrowing experiences of those
who had accessibility needs other
serious issues that were detailed
included misgendering streamers and
allegedly deleting messages are meant to
alert people of the streamer's correct
pronouns this was in addition to the
introduction of the panel saying woman
streamers when one of the streamers is
non-binary people also pointed out that
while attendees wearing masks were
eventually added to twitchcon policies
it seemed like no one was following the
rules and were putting Folks at risk and
yes before you ask it is in the official
Health measures that quote regardless of
vaccination status all attendees will be
required to wear a prude face coverings
to to enter and remain at twitchcon
users also reported that twitchcon
stopped doing bag checks and that some
content creators panels were completely
mismanaged for their size in addition to
all of this amaranth one of Twitter's
most prolific streamers said that a
stalker managed to show about twitchcon
which basically forced her to sequester
in her own room security had to get
involved as the stalker showed up just
because I have security that doesn't
mean I want the stalker to see me
so that's why I went up to the room and
then I got that message and it never
came down amaranth has had a pretty
serious ongoing issue with stalking as a
blade I don't know if this is the same
person but regardless it is something
that she has had to deal with in the
past there were also reports that
people's drinks being spiked as well as
an account of drugging and sexual
assault all this is what helped the
hashtag boycott twitch hashtag to be
used by people on Twitter who were fed
up with everything that allegedly been
happening at twitchcon twitch is at a
very rough past few months and by that
it means been called out consistently by
its Community for its lack of Equitable
treatment a fair Revenue split and the
complete lack of basic safety measures
for both online and in person and with
the lack of results and satisfactory
responses it seems like twitchcon is
just the latest in the Sago twitch being
unable to deliver for its users on the
most basic level of needs people's
well-being
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this then hit the sub
button and ring the notification Bell
for Unique bite size videos you won't
find anywhere else hit up our Twitter
Instagram Facebook and tick tock